[Music]
hey you guys time for another tomes of
terror book review
we got a good one for you today oh man
this one was like so awesome i had so
much fun with this one this one is the
amulet by michael mcdowell
now uh those of you that have been
watching my videos in this series will
know that i believe this is the third
michael mcdowell book that i covered the
third one that i've read actually uh the
first one i did was the elementals
which is kind of like his best known one
and uh then i also did cold moon over
babylon now michael mcdowell if you guys
don't know or if you didn't see the
other uh videos he was kind of like
probably best known nowadays for um
writing the original screenplay for
beetlejuice and the nightmare before
christmas
but he was also like a really popular um
author of paperback horror originals in
the 70s and 80s
and uh was kind of he was recommended by
stephen king like stephen king even like
talked about him in dance macabre and in
the book that i have by grady hendricks
paperbacks from hell he talks a lot
about michael mcdowell how a lot of his
stuff was uh was really popular during
the 80s but unfortunately most of it
went out of print i think like oh you
know a lot of those there was such a big
paperback boom in horror in the 80s and
it was just and a lot of the books to be
fair were not really that great
um so a lot of them went out of print
including his unfortunately but uh for
whatever reason i guess because you know
he had like other writers that were
always like pulling for him and stuff
like that
valoncourtbooks decided to reprint all
of his stuff from back in the 80s with
new covers new introductions stuff like
that so this one actually has a new
introduction written in 2013
by poppy z bright so that's when this
was republished in 2013.
this was originally published in 1979
and like i said this was his first uh
published novel and uh it's actually
although the story is actually set in
1965
now this one like i said this you know
i've read uh two of his other ones
called moon over babylon which this is
kind of more in line with that or and
the elementals which is kind of almost
like a weird like creepy
haunted house type story not really but
it's like a really original kind of
thing
this one
is just pretty much straight up
gory bloodbath fun you know what i mean
this one is just a [ __ ] blast it is
so so fun and it's just kind of like
i mean like from the beginning of it i
was kind of because i kind of feel like
i read some other reviews of this and
one of the main
there weren't a lot of complaints
because most of the reviews were really
good one of the complaints that some
people had was that it started out a
little slow because
michael mcdowell kind of like was laying
the groundwork of like this little town
where it was taking place and kind of
going in the ins and outs of who
everybody was and stuff like that i
don't know i didn't find that slow i
didn't find i thought it was like really
interesting but you know it's your
mileage is gonna vary you know maybe if
you're not into that kind of like scene
setting then maybe the beginning might
be slow but it did not seem that slow to
me at all in fact this was like a really
really quick read i read this in
like probably just like a few hours just
because i couldn't i kept like going
back to it because i couldn't put it
down because it's just i wanted to see
like how much more batshit insane it
could get so michael mcdowell uh he
passed away in 1999 unfortunately in the
aids epidemic
and uh so it's really nice that
valoncourt books uh and i said this on
my other uh michael mcdowell novel
reviews as well
that uh that they decided to kind of you
know bring his bring his stuff back in
the dead because it really really is
several several notches above a lot of
the just kind of like pulpy paperback
horror that came out in the 80s i mean
it's just so well written
and he's just really good at drawing
characters that really kind of come to
life and he's really good at like
establishing a sense of place so michael
mcdowell was actually born in alabama i
think he wasn't born too far away from
like the you know the alabama florida
state line so a lot of his stories are
very very southern like usually very
southern gothic and he really likes to
do these kind of like twisting family
relationships or like you know twisted
relationships between all the townsfolk
and stuff like that so that's kind of
and he's really really good at
conveying like what
what like rural southern
people are like like and what towns like
that are like because that's kind of how
he grew up so you know it's not
surprising that he's really good at
being able to convey that and a lot of
his stuff including this one has a lot
of very very very dark humor i will say
if you are
squeamish
if you do not want to read a book in
which
men women children babies
pretty much everybody dies in just
horrifically ridiculously gruesome ways
then this is not the book for you
because
holy [ __ ] this book is a bloodbath it's
just kind of every but like so many
people get killed like the body count is
enormous and everybody gets killed like
in a different way like and they and the
kills get more and more creative i've
seen this more than one person like when
i was reading reviews of it more than
one person wondered if this novel was
actually the inspiration for the final
destination movies just because the way
that like people die in this is just
like so it's so
rude goldbergian it's just like so
[ __ ] funny but it is this is very
very gruesome and like i said don't get
too attached to any of the characters
because pretty much all of them are
going to get killed in like really
really graphic ways but it's and i know
it's that's terrible but it's like if
you're into that kind of stuff like if
you're into like slasher movies but with
kind of like an old southern gothic feel
to it and like a lot of dark humor then
you will probably love this because i
just thought this book was so so [ __ ]
fun
so what the premise of this book is it's
set in this little bitty town called
pinecone alabama
and it's set in 1965.
so at the beginning we have this young
guy uh who's from there named dean
howell he's gonna be shipped off to
vietnam
so he's at like you know the training
you know the base or whatever and it so
happens that during a training exercise
the rifle that he's using uh essentially
explodes and blows most of his face off
uh so that's kind of like happens in the
first few pages
and uh from that point forward he's
pretty much a vegetable because it you
know it [ __ ] up his face like he's all
deformed and uh it [ __ ] up his part of
his brain too i'm imagining now
interestingly the rifles
uh were made in pine cone because
pinecone that's like their main uh
that's their main source of revenue is
this munitions factory that was put
there and pretty much everyone in the
town either works there or knows
somebody that works there and one of the
people that works there is dean's young
wife sarah who's 21 years old and they
haven't really been married all that
long
so after that happens so after he gets
his face blown off and obviously he's
like i said essentially a vegetable now
so they send him back to
pinecone
and sarah howell his wife now has to
take care of him
and not only that but they had to move
back in with dean's mother
joe
who is
the worst person ever she is just kind
of like this big fat
mean selfish horrible
woman who
will not like lift a finger to do
anything around the house because her
whole thing is that well
sarah and dean are living there rent
free
and so
sarah should just do everything around
the house even though it's joe's house
even though sarah has like a full-time
job she works at the munitions factory
and she works there 40 hours a week so
joe is there all day and basically just
sits around in her ass and watches tv
and then so sarah comes over work and
still has to make everybody dinner make
everybody breakfast make every lunch she
has to like do everything for everybody
and uh she's getting a little uh
you know
sick of it and uh joe is just kind of
like this horrible like passive
aggressive she's always making just sly
little comments about sarah she's not
doing enough she's not good enough she's
not this and that she's always like
blaming her for everything so after the
accident uh when they send dean back to
the house and basically all he can do
he's just like wrapped in bandages
and he just kind of lays around and
sarah is not even entirely sure
if
he's still like in there you know i mean
in the sense that because he can't talk
she's not really sure if he can hear
them uh so he's just basically like
sitting around like a mummy all the time
and she just has to feed him
and you know and she gets to a point
where it's just like is this gonna be
like the rest of my life like having to
feed him through the bandages he doesn't
he can't do anything he just lays there
and then his fat ass mom is just like
sitting around on her ass you know not
doing anything around the house like she
won't even wash a dish or anything like
that and just kind of like you know
sitting and then just kind of
excoriating sarah for not doing enough
for dean that's your husband you should
do this then the other thing so it's not
a great situation
the only kind of bright spot in sarah's
life is that she has a friend named
becca who lives next door uh and they
also work next to each other like on the
assembly line at the munitions factory
so after dean has the accident
joe pretty much blames everybody in the
town
for what happened to him
she's like basically if the guy that
managed the munitions factory had gave
him a job at the factory then he would
never have got sent off to vietnam uh so
he would have never even been at the
camp to start with or at the base to
start with and this wouldn't have
happened he also uh joe also blames
sarah for
essentially like making the guns that
did that even though she wasn't even
working there like when that gun was
made but it's like like i said joe
pretty much blames everybody and she's
kind of like
the way she is she's one of those people
who's like oh i do anything for my only
son and everything and ever i'm gonna
get everybody so she just blames the
whole entire town for what happened to
her son so the first person she blames
that she targets
is this dude named larry who's like the
manager and like i said he um didn't
give dean a job at the factory i can't
there was a good reason but i can't
remember what it was but he did um i
think he got uh or dean got drafted like
before there was an opening at the
factory i think that's what it was so
larry was like i totally would have
given him a job but then he got drafted
and there wasn't an opening for him or
anything like that but as soon as an
opening came up he actually gave the job
to sarah instead as kind of like a
consolation prize or whatever so they
would you know have some more money
so this guy you know even though he's a
good guy joe for what for you know for
that reason because she blames everybody
she's like well it's his fault if he had
you know if dean had been working at the
factory none of this would have happened
so one day she gives when larry comes
over to see dean she gives larry this
amulet
and it looks very much like uh the one
you see right here on the cover it's
kind of like it's black and with like a
gold thing in the middle and then it has
like a black uh kind of a black stone in
the middle of it it's kind of like
modern looking and it's on like a gold
chain so sarah thinks all of this is
very weird because joe never
particularly liked larry uh or his wife
and five children never really gave a
[ __ ] about them before it's like so why
is she all of a sudden giving him a
present like to give to
his wife it's like you know it just
doesn't make any sense to her but she's
kind of like okay whatever and larry
thinks it's very weird too he's just
kind of like okay thanks
and another thing too is that sarah has
never seen that amulet before she
doesn't know where it came from
and uh so that also kind of makes her a
little bit suspicious
now after like pretty much the same day
that larry uh gets the amulet and gives
it to his wife rachel
the amulet has a weird has a really
weird property where
it kind of like you can't ever find the
catch like how it how the chain opens
but somehow it always just kind of like
pulls apart and then it kind of like
almost sort of puts itself onto your
neck like without you really realizing
you know what i mean and then kind of
like locks back on
so
that's what ends up happening now
interestingly
what th this isn't really a spoiler like
i said although this probably will have
like some spoilers in it if you just
want to go into this blind uh without
knowing what's g what's happening you
know then maybe you might want to like
click off now but it's like i said it's
not a real like complicated story it's
basically just
you know once the amulet gets into like
one family's hands it's basically just
like one big long
chain of events and like just
escalating mayhem like throughout this
town as this amulet goes because the
amulet is essentially cursed is what it
is
um so and and it just kind of so the so
the book kind of goes
follows the amulet like throughout the
town and you know the increasingly
horrible things that happen to everybody
that gets it so it's that kind of thing
so basically the same day that uh that
larry and his wife get the amulet rachel
like she does some [ __ ] up [ __ ] like
she burns their house down like she
drugs their she drugs the kids and she
drugs her husband so they can't so they
can't leave they can't get up and then
she burns the house down so all all of
them like the the couple and their five
kids all burn up and their house just
like [ __ ] burns to the ground now
everyone in town is horrified of course
because there's an entire family that
was you know quite well liked and they
all get wiped out in this big huge fire
but nobody really thinks anything about
it
uh at first
now like i said this book it's kind of
like a series of events you know what i
mean it's it's just kind of like stuff
keeps escalating but we do have a main
protagonist in sarah howell
who even though stuff kind of goes back
and forth because
how the structure of the book is is
basically like you know the amulet will
be somewhere and then who like something
really really bad will happen like
people will you know one person will die
two people will die a whole family will
die or whatever and then the amulet will
somehow get into the hands of someone
else like it'll pass to someone else and
then something will happen to them so
there's kind of like each chapter is
sort of like setting up
the people that got the amulet kind of
like and kind of like giving um a little
bit of like a character thing which like
i said this is why
michael mcdowell is really good at
very efficiently describing these
characters and making you care about
them like right before like in a few
pages and then a couple pages later he
just like dispatches them in just
horrible grotesque ways so it's almost
kind of like i like this book a lot
because just like the tone of it was so
gleeful you could tell that he was
having like such a good time being like
look at these nice people and like
having them interact with each other and
then he's like bam that he's like just
like what's the most horrific way i
could kill these people like and i could
just like picture him like laughing
maniacally so it just seems like so
basically nobody in this is safe i don't
care if you like that character i don't
care if it's a nice person i don't care
if it's a bad person i don't care if
it's a baby no one gets spared like if
this amulet like falls into someone's
hands some bad [ __ ] is gonna happen and
there's like nothing you could do about
it so it's kind of like so it kind of
gets to a point where you know you're
introduced to a new family or a new
person or whatever and you're like oh
this is a cool person i was like
shame what's gonna happen to them but
then it's this like i said it's kind of
like a slasher movie in the sense that
yes you like the characters but
you're just waiting to see you're
waiting for the shoe to drop you're
waiting to see what horrible thing is
gonna happen to these people and uh so
the whole book is kind of like that but
you also have sarah howell like i said
it was a young woman and she is kind of
like uh the main protagonist like the
center of the action because she
since she lives with joe and she knows
that joe her mother-in-law is like such
a horrible garbage person
then she's pretty sure
that
joe knew what that amulet was gonna do
and that it's cursed and so she kind of
makes it her mission because obviously
she can't really tell anybody because
they wouldn't believe her because you
know what you know that that would be
dumb as you go to the cops and be like
yeah there's this amulet and it's cursed
and whenever
it falls into somebody's hands and they
put it on what usually ends up happening
is that when you put it on it's almost
like it makes you
murderous you know what i mean so
someone will put it on and then they'll
be like man my husband sucks and then
they like just stick a um like a ice
pick in their brain or whatever
and you know then burn the house down or
you know whatever it is so it'll do that
but then the bird the person that
murdered the you know the one that with
the amulet on will kill themselves
accidentally you know what i mean like
for example
there's one scene where these two girls
and it's one girl um they're friends but
one of them is like has a beauty parlor
and she's working on the other girl's
hair because she has a date that night
and uh so she has the amulet on because
she got it through this like really
complicated series of events
and then so she decides she's you know
as soon as they put it on like you can
kind of he writes about their thoughts
and it's all of a sudden they start
feeling like really uncharitable toward
this person like it's like what the [ __ ]
why won't she shut up why won't she do
this and that the other and they get
really like cranky and so so the girl
like takes some chemicals or something
like that from her beauty parlor and
basically like puts it on the girl's
scalp and just starts pulling all her
hair out and her scalp starts dissolving
and all this other kind of [ __ ] so it's
like she kills her friend but then like
when she's going up um to get something
like off a shelf or whatever she falls
and like the ceiling fan decapitates her
so it's so it's that kind of thing so
whenever the murderer
you know they murder a person like in a
really horrible way
but then they die themselves
accidentally like in a crazy you know
it's like there there's one where you
know the a girl like kills a baby by
like put it in the washing machine that
was a pretty [ __ ] up scene and then
she
falls like she slips and falls in the
suds and i think she falls like on some
gla on some broken glass or something
from earlier but then like she um puts
her hand on the cord or the washing
machine like electric keats herself it's
so it's all this other kind of stuff
like i said it's nothing that it's very
very final destination but because it's
played with such
humor i think one of the things i loved
about this and this is very because i
grew up in the south too um and this is
very true to life like i said this is
set in 1965
and it does have some stuff like that
like there is some kind of like there's
still you know it's alabama so there's
still like racial segregation and that's
kind of like a big thing like a big
background thing in the story and like i
said vietnam is going on and stuff like
that other than that it's not real it
doesn't seem dated it doesn't seem like
you know it doesn't seem like nostalgic
or anything like that because like i
said it's just this gleeful like gore
fest and there are some things about it
that are that you know point to it being
1965 but it's not it doesn't like smack
you in the face with it or anything so
you know so so don't go into it like
thinking it's oh it's this big nostalgia
it's not really like that but what i
mean one of my favorite things about it
is just kind of like this tone of
you know obviously everybody in this
town this is a very small town there's
only like a few thousand people and
everyone kind of like knows each other
and so when somebody gets killed like
everybody hears about it and everybody's
like freaking out about it but they're
also like kind of ghoulish because
they're always
you know they'll have like uh you know
some horrible thing will happen and then
immediately like everyone will come up
with like all this gossip and stuff and
they'll just like make up stuff to make
this [ __ ] even crazier than it was
and
the funny thing too is that a lot of the
people like even when they find the
bodies like
you know what i mean and like i said
some of these people die in like
ridiculously horrible ways even when
they find the bodies most people are
really just kind of like
they're not like overly hysterical
they'll just be
kind of like
well that kind of thing will happen you
know i mean it's like that kind of thing
it's hard for me to explain but i don't
know i really really found that very
very funny but also like realistic it's
funny but it also
it also kind of like resonated with me
like rang true with me because that is
what a lot of like rural southerners are
like so i mean he's really got a he had
a really good ear for
for that for this kind of rural southern
culture like the way they talk um you
know he's very very good at capturing
that cadence of their speech and the
different kind of like phrases that they
use and stuff like that so it is a
really very i mean it's not a long novel
i think it's like under 300 pages but
it's very very and there's a lot of
characters but all of them are very very
vividly drawn and in a very brief time
which i think is really great um i think
the only i mean i i didn't mind this at
all i think that some people did
be like well you know it does get kind
of repetitive after or you know what's
going to happen obviously because
as soon as somebody new gets the amulet
and they you know we are we are
establishing how they got it and like
you know what's gonna happen then um you
know you know what's gonna happen but i
that really did not diminish my
enjoyment of it at all i mean like i
said this is basically like
like a really really great
super super gory [ __ ] up slasher movie
that you just kind of like sit and watch
popcorn and be like oh my god these are
are they really going to put that baby
in the watch yep there it goes right the
baby in the washing machine you know
what i mean so it's it's just kind of
like that like i said it's not going to
be for everybody obviously but if you're
into this kind of like black humor
super super over the top like i said if
you like the final destination movies
you will probably [ __ ] love this
because i can totally see how
whoever wrote the final destination
movies i've only seen like the first one
or two whoever wrote the final
destination movies maybe read this and
we're like yeah that sounds like a cool
idea because this the structure of it is
very very similar but like i said i
really really liked and i really liked
the the whole southern uh vibe to with
the southern patois like all of the
phrases that they use and stuff like
that because i was like oh my god that's
what she said that just sounded like
something my grandma would say and
something like that so it's like i don't
know i i just really in case you can't
tell i just had so so much fun with this
book it is just so entertaining it was
so entertaining i didn't actually mean
for this to happen but honestly it was
kind of a nice i don't want to say
palette cleanser but um you know since
last week i reviewed house of leaves
which is a very complex
uh complicated puzzle type of thing that
you really have to like pay attention to
so it was kind of neat and like i said i
didn't know this going into it but it
was kind of neat that like you know the
week after it i just got this fun breezy
crazy gruesome it you know like i said
it's just a blast it's just a ride and
uh honestly
i think i might like this one i mean the
elementals is
amazing
um i need to read some of his other
stuff too like everybody says like the
blackwater saga is really good so that
might be i mean that's longer but um i
might get into that too but i think and
i loved cold moon over babylon but i
think i might have liked this one a
little bit better even though this is
first book
it is very there is first published
novel i guess uh but it's very very
self-assured like i said it's just it's
so great it's just such a fun roller
coaster ride that you can just kind of
like sit back and be like all right what
kind of [ __ ] up shit's gonna happen
now like i said if you do not want to
see like
you know dozens and dozens of people
including babies children i was like die
in just horrible ways
then
maybe not so much then maybe this is not
for you because
yeah it's like i said nobody is safe in
this but
if you're into like over-the-top slasher
movies then you will probably really
really dig this i mean i i just thought
this was
this was amazingly fun and wonderful so
you know check it out uh if you would
like to
and let me know what you thought about
it if you've read it and that will do it
for this tomes of terror i'll see you
guys on the next one bye